listen to lyrics he says I try to take
off once I face them in this hablo fit I
just changed my name to double long
because I'm really rich n words on that
silly come to this inside the business
killing and this brings us to the end of
The Saga because it is in the end a
Greek tragedy which is exactly what I
thought or more reminiscent maybe of
19th century Russian literature shades
of Dostoyevsky Crime and Punishment
young boy playing the role of of course
Russ konikov choosing corruption in the
end you know he chooses sin he sheds the
shell of Youth he breaks free from its
innocence and suddenly he has no time he
says for that silly the frivolity and
playfulness of Youth he rejects it I'm
not young boy he says I'm a young man
but for him to stake his claim in the
world to make his own Mark to achieve
the recognition that he believes he's
owed he must descend into brutality
inside the business killing so a young
boy here with this Jam is is giving us
the Prelude there's a whole story still
left to be told a chance even for a
happy ending ultimate but that's a story
for another day one yet to be told